[Music]
the events now you when you when you go
anywhere and there's an event and fans
are gonna be there for Hunger Games it's
just insanity you've seen and you've
been all around the world bored in this
film people make up signs and you've
seen some crazy ones seen some very
crazy signs it started off kind of you
know on the smaller side like we love
PETA we heart P a team Peeta and then it
was like cuz my character Peeta he's a
baker and and it started like you can
put your loaf in my oven and and then
and then it was like is that a loaf of
bread in your pocket are you just happy
to see me and then like you guys are the
guys I hope these are girls I'm not sure
how old they were but I was like where
are your parents I was kind of worried
about that because 16 will get you 20
yeah so you don't want to be messing
around that zone I'm glad you told me
but this changes my evening plans
completely on that no there's also a
pedophile it's an I'm a pedophile which
is kinda crazy but then there's one is
funny I'm a pedophile they had one that
was these two girls had these then there
are two head cutouts and they put their
faces in it and just I'd want to have a
threesome there's nothing to do with the
film no and then the best place is going
but you're mad about the artlessness
right but the fact that you just have
some class
come on it's all about district 3 riding
riding tweeter and tweener come-ons I
guess yeah what so what you had you
brought will show in a second but you
brought a picture of the weirdest yeah
the rears won't send it up and there's
Peeta and there's Katniss and you know
they're like that combined is like
Brangelina right and Peeta and Katniss
can lead to peace oh there we go I think
we saw it we have this photo here so and
that's my face of like yep we are penis
go while stand behind the sign that's
your mistake when I see that sign it
don't come patch it forward
I heart penis you happy right that
promote that you're right we had girls
come up to us when we're doing signings
with me and Jennifer and and they would
say I love pinis and Jennifer our first
like we can't we stay to that and
they're like oh Peeta Katniss okay
that's okay right it's good Eliza me
that's not a okay no no it's not okay
mining we all get that it's it's
probably better than cat peed
[Applause]
I still think Jackie it's the better now
what break it down for me you tell you a
lot about because there's there's two
types that are coming to these events
that are getting real crazy it's it's
the the teenage girls and it's the moms
and sometimes I hear it's the moms it
can be almost as intense as the teenage
girls we have them yeah because a lot of
times you had these little girls that
just like want to say hi and meet you
and I hi nice to meet you yeah and the
moms when they take a picture take a
picture take a picture do the sign this
sign this sign is and the daughters like
oh my god mom stop you're so
embarrassing right now right and and I
feel bad for the kids sometimes there's
just one mom every time I go to New York
City she invites me to come to dinner
with her and her daughter every single
time and her daughter just like yeah we
can go to dinner and her mom like comedy
no it doesn't be amazing but actually
today on my flight from Cincinnati back
home to here I had a stewardess that
that want me to sign something for her
daughter and then she says my daughter
she's really hot I was like is if she
wasn't hot I wouldn't decide it like
this like the stealing be all she's hot
that's not weird for a mom to say yeah
exactly like my daughter she's real